what do you wish that people on Wall
Street understood about the crypto
community that maybe they don't like
what is the biggest disconnect that if
that got solved you think a lot of this
would would kind of be easier that that
that were all druggies and dark web
users and yeah there's still an enormous
overhang of that perception in the
community and from Wall Street's
perspective yeah III say all the time I
say the the currency of choice of every
drug dealer terrorists you know money
launderer in the world the US dollar and
the other piece do I think that you know
Wall Street hasn't yet figured out is
there's a general I know in law force
community who said look from our
perspective we want every criminal to
commit crimes with their hands on a
keyboard yeah right and so Bitcoin is a
perfect example of what can occur when
there is the you know kind of the
trackability etc of a currency it's more
trackable than US dollars for sure and I
believe FinCEN's
the new head of FinCEN just came out and
said that speaking out of Bitcoin
conference or blockchain event in
Chicago if I'm not mistaken and and said
exactly that this is actually more
traceable than the US dollar now that
they understand how to trace it it's
amazing yeah
okay so let's fast forward let's Wall
Street bangs a head against the wall for
a while right nice kind of broke the
seal we've ten fifteen twenty years from
now what do quote-unquote retail
products in crypto look like once washer
gets involved like what what do you
think are the the kind of most obvious
things is an ETF is it something else
what does that look like well I do think
it's an ETF and again that's a
double-edged sword there are a lot of
folks who are thinking that that's going
to be a savior of the price correction
that we've had in crypto and I'm not so
sure about that
and and I just saw Tour de Meester make
reference to the when the gold ETF was
introduced I think gold prices were up
350 percent within that period and
there's a big difference between the
between what Wall Street was back then
in 2004 and what Wall Street is today
there's so much more securities lending
and rehypothecation of collateral than
happened back then and so the price
action was more pure and
and now I'm not so sure because of I was
just talking over the weekend up at a
free state picnic with some folks who
work in the Wall Street industry we were
just comparing notes and we were talking
about the securities lending market and
and how basically after the financial
crisis so many of the mutual funds
especially defined contribution plans
like 401 K is turned off securities
lending after the Northern Trust Fund
had a problem with securities lending
and the entire defined contribution
market went non lending a lot of the
defined benefit market went not let non
lending as well and everyone in the
lending market thought well gosh
securities are we're gonna have a lot
more you know spreads are gonna widen
out we're gonna make more profit on what
we're trading and we're gonna have a lot
more scarce assets that's sort of hard
to borrow or special assets that are
that are so meaty for Wall Street to
intermediate because the profit margins
are so wide and guess what actually the
number of scarce and hard to borrow
assets went down you took out the entire
defined contribution and defined
benefits markets out of securities
lending how did that happen
the reason is because the accounting
systems are manipulatable shall we say
so I don't think that looking back at
the 2004 gold example is is actually
we're not gonna see a replay of that
because Wall Street has figured out how
to reallocate assets and that whole
securities finance market has has now
consolidated it used to be very
disparate but what was happening was the
hedge funds were are being the
investment banks funding desks
themselves so they'd go they'd go to the
prime brokerage desk and and put on one
side of the trade and then take the
other side of the trade with the repo
desk at the same investment bank and
collapsed and collect a spread because
the two part of the two parts of the
investment bank weren't working with
each other and they were pricing things
differently and now what's happened is
that's all consolidated at all the
investment banks into one department and
so all those different places where
assets are lent and relent in any sort
of rehypothecation I'm using that form
that that term very broadly but that's
how that's how Wall Street makes its
money
and there's so much more of that than
happened back 15 20 years ago